christina hall and heather ray el musa
on the sidelines and making headlines
for getting into a heated argument it's
my life and i need to do what i'm
comfortable with and i need to move
forward and be happy check out the
photos the reality stars at a kids
soccer game in newport beach their
conversation seemingly intense heather's
husband tariq al-musa and christina's
husband joshua hall appeared to be
involved too you can see targ pulling
heather away from the argument by the
arm you'll remember heather married
tarek christina's x last year so what
unfolded between the couples well they
released a joint statement telling et
quote a personal matter was discussed
and has since been resolved we are
focused on co-parenting as a team moving
forward we're always going to continue
to co-parent together and remain friends
so
it's just something that we're gonna
continue to do in the future meanwhile a
source tells et that heather and
christina well they haven't been getting
along i trust my guy i trust my
intuitions and so far they haven't
steered me wrong quote heather feels
like christina doesn't treat her
respectfully but the source adds that
heather on the other hand has tried
really hard to have a healthy blended
family where all of them can get along
i'm helping raise the kid so i think she
knew like how important my role was and
she's my ex-wife so the different
we have our own life and we respect her
as their mom and we co-parents so how
does tariq feel about the situation
between his wife and ex our source tells
us that he quote wants to protect
heather from all of it and thinks the
way christina has acted towards her is
unacceptable well i think like his
support means everything like he's like
the best husband the best
like i don't think i couldn't do it
without him he lets me parent how i want
and he never micromanages anything e.t
has reached out to christina's rep for
comment
these new photos were snapped just one
day before christina antarc revealed
their six-year-old son braden had
emergency surgery on sunday and it seems
the exes put saturday's tiff behind them
to support their little boy tarik
heather and christina all came together
each sharing posts about the emotional
day to instagram christina revealed
braden had an appendectomy and thanked
the hospital staff saying she was
grateful they caught it early tariq
shared a similar sentiment calling the
day very scary but adds we all band
together as a family to get through it
honestly seeing tarik as a daddy like he
loves those kids he's so obsessed with
the with them and when we don't have
them he's like i miss them i miss them
and and i do too like we love having
them around we miss them tarek's always
been vocal about his love for his kids
like when i say i'm obsessed with taylor
and braden like i'm obsessed like
obsessed and now he and wife heather are
taking steps to expand their family by
having a child of their own i'm ready
i've already made the decision or having
a kid i'm obsessed with the kids i'm
gonna coach their sports like i'm gonna
do it all the other day he made me so
happy because he goes
like twice in the same day
i remember we were in the garage we were
pulling in from soccer and he goes i'm
just so excited to have a baby and i'm
like